email kukuda
MOOC unison
portable
fight
such austerity sugar
listen
no to you it's security
please welcome from Bandai Namco's game
director Katsuhiro Harada and game
designer Michael Murray sorry I need to
cancel my autograph
today we're happy to announce a tekken 7
it's coming dead spots one consequence -
gay matosinhos income rom secured Oh
mrs. O'Neil - the other time create a
seamless instance maybe story mondobot
oh sorry mother not only what Tekken 7
evolved as a competitive fighting game
as you just saw there is an all-new
story mode the transition seamlessly
from epic narrative cinematics to action
filled gameplay how do I beat this guy
he's ng no no no no the key block ahead
you can eat it is Saitama Thomas
Kongo hope your father Giovanni Mohawk
sacrifice I hope you all are excited to
hear more info coming soon on story mode
and other impressive features we have
planned for the game when it ships in
early 2017 fight on us Rodimus
pondichery sukham xbox llama 1 bang take
10 several have broken instead they can
talk the truth they start about Xbox the
rival quagga diving board ok I'm ok knee
presenter cosmos one more exciting piece
of news all week we're giving Xbox Live
Gold members a free copy of Tekken Tag
Tournament 2 via backward compatibility
so download it today and start honing
your skills thank you have a great day
three week